[Music]
apple cider is also known as sweet cider
or soft cider
it's darker and cloudier than
conventional apple juice because tiny
bits of apple
are not filtered out these flavorful
fragments are what makes this fall
beverage unique
when the apples on the trees are ripe
it's time to produce
apple cider they process the apples
within days of the harvest
to produce a beverage that tastes both
fresh and sweet
it starts with the right mix of apples
some varieties are sweet and others are
tart
this mix of flavors will spice things up
the apples float to the surface of a
water-filled pit
and drift onto a conveyor that takes
them into the cider mill
inside the mill the apples spill into a
washing station
water sprays the apples as they bounce
across rolling brushes
[Music]
next the apples take a trip up to a
grinder
inside a steel arm pushes the apples
against the grater
it shreds them pits and all into a pulp
this pulp is known as pumice
the pumice lands in a funnel
from here a pump moves it through pipes
across the plant
where it arrives at a press
[Music]
the apple pumice flows between two
porous belts that wind around rollers
the rollers apply pressure to squeeze
out the juice
the juice drips through holes in the
belts
the process strains out most of the pulp
but some remains
as the juice spills from the press into
large catch pans
[Music]
then they pump this chunky apple liquid
into a holding tank
from the tank it flows through a
revolving drum
that filters out more pulp pits and
apple stems
the fluid seeps through the perforations
in the drum and flows into a large
trough
after one more screening only fine bits
of apple and sediment remain
this gives it the desired cider
consistency and flavor
the cider now flows into channels
between hot steel plates
the heat destroys pathogens and bacteria
that would convert the natural sugars to
alcohol
this ensures that the cider is both safe
to drink and non-alcoholic
it's now ready for bottling a worker
slides plastic jugs into position under
nozzles
the nozzles descend and pump the boiling
hot apple cider into the jugs
they're filled to the brim so air can't
get inside
air causes the cider to deteriorate
next the conveyor moves the jugs forward
to a capping station
plastic caps funnel toward the jugs as
they approach
the caps land on the rims with perfect
timing
spinning wheels tighten the caps as the
jugs ride by
hermetically sealing the hot apple cider
giving it a shelf life of approximately
a year
the jugs then head into a tunnel where
sprayers douse them with cold water
[Music]
next machinery pulls the liner off of
adhesive-backed labels
an electric eye detects the approaching
jugs cueing rollers to apply the labels
the filtered out pumice from earlier is
cooked four to five hours
this caramelizes the sugars in the
apples turning the pumice into a highly
concentrated spread
known as apple butter
they bottle it while it's piping hot to
preserve it
although not technically butter this
fruit spread has a similar consistency
[Music]
it takes a full day of processing to
produce both apple butter and apple
cider
it's time to raise a glass and enjoy the
sweet bounty of the harvest
you